hey y'all welcome to another episode of
is this okay where we talk about things
and ask the question is this okay there
we go I'm Jenny
I'm deja I'm niala I'm Chris I'm Becky
today we're gonna talk about a very
scary topic of how we pop - okay so this
topic came about when I saw a lot of
articles being written about the Moana
costume or as like this costume where it
was like you know full tats and also you
could see like the brown skin underneath
the tats so I would like to ask friends
where do you draw the line with
offensive costumes well for me
personally you see like sexy Indian and
then we also see the warrior when I see
Asian costumes because a lot of it it
actually appeals to a very pan Asian
like like all Japanese and Chinese
they're basically the same thing for
instance like that MLK party and it was
like come dressed as black people and
it's like so then you have people
throwing up gang signs and wearing baggy
clothes and doing all this [ __ ] but when
have you ever seen a party of being like
oh come dressed as white people if I
wore an offensive costume that offended
you or something and I were to say to
you Chris it's just a costume like get
over it's just Halloween like how would
you react to that people are like it's
just a costume it's just a movie it's
just a game it's just it's it's just a
kids show yeah it's it's just something
because you everyone thinks that
it's just this one thing it normalizes a
lot of these horrible like mindsets of
like oh well I thought black people just
look like this I thought Asian people
just look like this I thought Native
people just look like Americans
Streatham you would not believe the
number of people who actually seriously
in all seriousness will ask me but isn't
that the way Native Americans dress is
it just a matter of doing your research
if someone came to me and said you know
I want a dress as Pocahontas for
Halloween or I want a dress as crazy
horse for Halloween I'd be like great
learn about them what tribes they were
from what their traditions were how they
actually dressed what their actual
history was not just I'm generically
dressing in this weird little buckskin
fringe and calling it Pocahontas if you
don't know anything about the character
you're dressing as why do you want to
dress these bad character in the first
place wouldn't you rather dress as
something that you are impressed by that
you do that you do have some knowledge
how can you say that you're trying to
honor those people in that culture you'd
even take two seconds to look it up but
there's also like stems from education
though to is like I just I think like we
can all sit here and say like it takes
two seconds to look it up and it's easy
peasy lemon squeezy for us because we're
all culturally competent but I think
like you know you have these
universities that have story after story
after story of blackface and cultural
appropriation Dean's excuse it so it's
kind of like well if the deans are
excusing it then it's okay that we can
do do you hold them accountable as much
as you hold the school accountable
because they're not holding the students
accountable yeah I mean like everyone
needs to be held accountable actually a
lot of schools are telling kids to be
cognizant of the fact that they could be
offensive and it's the kids that are
fighting against their right it was it
was a master actually was a faculty
member or staff member who actually said
is that goes beyond like only white
people doing it I think that it is
important that we like look deeper into
this and kind of dismantle systemic
racism and figure out ways like
Halloween itself just perpetuates all
these stereotypes it's not one specific
group that does it I think you know the
holiday and not only the holiday yeah
it's not just racist misogyny as
homophobia all of ya phobia you know
Islamophobia it's all of these things so
a while ago I had a friend who dressed
up as a black celebrity that he really
loved he wore blackface and B were going
to a party and we had a black friend of
ours who thought it was really funny it
was all about this idea of the costume
was great and they talked about how but
just not upset anybody they would not
put the photos on Facebook it still felt
a little odd to me but they were like if
no one else is seeing it and everyone
else here knows that we are not racist
and we all think the blackface is funny
then there's no harm no foul the black
friend of mine essentially said don't
you know don't be offended on behalf of
black people like I'm saying if I'm the
only one here that sees this and I'm
okay and I'm comfortable with it it
should be it should be okay okay
just because you and you and the fact
that you are a black person thought that
it was funny like you have to understand
that as a whole community that sets us
back
I feel very mixed about it because like
you're allowed to have your opinion like
like we're all individuals and and like
Asian people black people like we all
don't have a hive mind and so we all
don't have to like think the same way
about things again both of those people
are fine you can live in the same world
but the person that's not offended has
no right to tell the other person that
they shouldn't be offended okay even if
he's the only black person at that party
you all live in the world and everybody
else is taking that experience and the
sort of assumption that this is okay
back into the real world and that feeds
into a continuing problem it seems like
the next question is then what do we do
about how they keep happening and it
seemed like you guys were saying that
you want the schools to take more
responsibility but at what point can
this then does the school then I'm happy
to educate what are you gonna say you
just I'm gonna give to prove your
costume with us know for instance I went
to a school and somebody had wrote the
word [ __ ] on the wall I think they
said I wish all [ __ ] would die
something like that and so instead of
like specifically going after the
individual the school then said okay
somebody clearly thought that this was a
space in which they could say something
like that so we're gonna re-evaluate the
space and we're gonna create programming
to talk about these things and to create
a different kind of environment that we
actually want to foster so that no one
ever thinks that this is a space that
they can write that kind of stuff it's a
tough issue that I hope that we all
think about yeah yeah so you already
know what to do leave your comments in
the comment section below to each other
yeah and we'll see you next week
[Music]